This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There is a beauty to a universal standard. The idea that people across the world can agree that when they interact with one specific thing everyone will be on the same page. Regardless of language or culture or geographic locale, if I'm in Belgrade, or geographic locale. If I'm in Belgrade, Orshenghai, or Sao Paulo, I can look at a sign and know instantly without speaking a word of the local language that this floor is slippery.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。通用标准有一种独特的美感。当全球各地的人们在与某个特定事物互动时，大家都能够达成一致，处于同一频道。不论语言、文化或地理位置如何，如果我在贝尔格莱德、奥森盖或圣保罗，我看到一个标志，就能瞬间明白，甚至不需要说一句当地语言，就知道这个地板很滑。
That the emergency exit is over there and that that substance is poisonous and I should not eat it. The group behind those internationally recognized logos is called ISO, the International Organization for Standardization. That's reporter Lauren Oberg. And one of the most recognizable ISO symbols is the International symbol of access. That's the formal name of the blue and white logo with the stick figure in a wheelchair.
应急出口就在那边，某种物质是有毒的，我不应该食用它。那些国际公认徽标背后的组织叫做ISO，即国际标准化组织。这是记者劳伦·奥伯。ISO最知名的标志之一就是国际无障碍符号。这是那个带有轮椅人形图案的蓝白标志的正式名称。
Around the world you see the international symbol of access everywhere. Parking spaces, on buttons that operate automatic doors, in bathrooms, and on seats on the bus or at movie theaters. Anywhere where there's an indication of special accommodations made for people with disabilities. Prior to the late 1960s, there was no universally agreed upon accessibility icon. Everyone used a different symbol if they bothered to use one at all. But in the 1960s, the Disability Rights Movement started picking up steam. In 1968, a group now called Rehabilitation International announced a design contest to create an international symbol of access. The logo would have to be readily identifiable from a reasonable distance, self-descriptive, simple, unambiguous, and practical.
在世界各地，你到处都能看到国际无障碍符号。停车位、自动门按钮、洗手间、公交车上或电影院的座位上。任何标明为残障人士提供特殊便利的地方都有。在20世纪60年代末之前，并没有一个普遍认可的无障碍图标。如果大家勉强使用一个的话，每个人都会用不同的符号。但在20世纪60年代，残疾人权利运动开始蓬勃发展。1968年，一个如今被称为“国际康复”的组织宣布了一场设计竞赛，旨在创造一个国际无障碍符号。该标志必须能够在合理距离内被轻易识别、具有自我说明性、简单、明确且实用。
The winner was a Danish designer named Susana Kufuul. The modern stick figure in wheelchair logo that we know today is actually a slightly modified version from the original. That one didn't have a head. Within a decade, the logo, the one with a head, was endorsed by both the United Nations and ISO. Remember, this is the group that sets iconographic standards across countries. And so over time, this logo, the International Symbol of Access, began to get embedded in the urban fabric of cities and towns across the world. People began to pay attention to the kinds of special building accommodations that spaces need to be inviting for people with varying degrees of ability.
获胜者是一位名叫苏珊娜·库福尔的丹麦设计师。我们今天所知道的现代轮椅人形标志实际上是原版的一个稍微修改过的版本。原版是没有头部的。在十年之内，带头部的那个标志得到了联合国和ISO的认可。请记住，这就是那个在各国之间制定图标标准的组织。因此，随着时间的推移，这个标志——国际无障碍符号——开始融入世界各地城市和城镇的城市结构中。人们开始关注各种特殊的建筑便利设施，这些设施对于让不同能力程度的人能够融入其中是必不可少的。
And then in 1990, Congress passed the landmark Americans with Disabilities Act, which President George H. W. Bush signed into law. The ADA was modeled on the Civil Rights Act of 1964. The law, and I'm reading this from the ADA website here, quote, prohibits discrimination and guarantees that people with disabilities have the same opportunities as everyone else to participate in the mainstream of American life, to enjoy employment opportunities, to purchase goods and services, and to participate
然后在1990年，国会通过了具有里程碑意义的《美国残疾人法案》，并由乔治·H·W·布什总统签署成为法律。ADA是以1964年的《民权法案》为蓝本的。该法律，我是从ADA的网站上读到的，引用：“禁止歧视，并确保残疾人与其他人享有平等的机会，参与美国生活的主流，享受就业机会，购买商品和服务，以及参与……”
in state and local government programs and services. End quote. And I think it's fair to say that having a single attractive logo to signify a universal right for access helped create an atmosphere in which the built world could begin to adapt to new building parameters and regulations as specified per the ADA. In many ways, the adoption of the international accessibility icon is a success story in a simple design changing the world for the better.
“……州和地方政府的项目和服务。”引用结束。我认为可以公平地说，拥有一个单一且引人注目的标志来象征对无障碍的普遍权利，有助于营造一种氛围，使得建成环境能够根据ADA的规定开始适应新的建筑参数和法规。在许多方面，国际无障碍图标的采纳是一个成功的故事，它通过简单的设计让世界变得更美好。
I think the current image always has to be lauded for its historic importance. It's a form of wayfinding, it's a form of easy navigation in the environment, and it's historically profound. I mean, it's politically so important that now you know you're guaranteed when you go out you're gonna find one of these spaces that's preserved. You're able to count on accommodation. But this isn't the end of the story because as the logo got absorbed into the built environment people with disabilities and their
我认为当前的图像因其历史重要性而始终值得赞扬。它是一种寻路方式，是环境中轻松导航的一种形式，并且具有深刻的历史意义。我的意思是，它在政治上如此重要，以至于现在你知道你出门时可以保证找到这些保留的空间之一。你能够指望得到便利。但这并不是故事的全部，因为随着这个标志被融入建成环境，残疾人及其……
allies started finding it kind of lacking. The shapes of the body and the body parts on that icon are squared off in geometric. And even though it does have a head. The head dangles from the neck, and the neck is in this kind of unnaturally erect posture. There's not a sense of organic shapes of the body in space. That's Sarah Hendren, by the way. My name is Sarah Hendren.
盟友们开始发现它有些不足。该图标上的身体形状和身体部位都是方形和几何形的。尽管它确实有一个头，但头从脖子上垂下来，而且脖子处于一种很不自然的直立姿势。空间中的身体并没有一种有机形态的感觉。顺便说一句，那是萨拉·亨德伦。我的名字是萨拉·亨德伦。
I'm an artist and design researcher in Cambridge, Massachusetts and I think a lot about prosthetics, adaptive technologies and disability studies and disability politics. Sarah Hendren is also a lecturer at RISD, the Rhode Island School of Design. And most importantly for our purposes, Sarah is the co-founder of the Accessible Icon Project. This movement, because that's what I think it has become, a movement, is made up of designers, activists, artists, academics, and disability advocates all trying to change the conversation about disability in their communities.
我是马萨诸塞州剑桥市的一名艺术家和设计研究员，我经常思考假肢、自适应技术、残疾研究和残疾政治。萨拉·亨德伦也是罗德岛设计学院（RISD）的讲师。对于我们的目的而言，最重要的是，萨拉是“无障碍图标项目”的联合创始人。这个运动——因为我认为它已经变成了这样，一场运动——由设计师、活动家、艺术家、学者和残疾倡导者组成，他们都在努力改变社区中关于残疾的对话。
And so for starters, the Accessible Icon Project has taken aim at the standard blue and white wheelchair icon. They've created a new icon that they hope will ultimately replace the ISO standard. It's still a white figure in a wheelchair positioned in a blue field, but the head and body are tilted forward. The arm is angled back as if it's propelling the user, and the wheel looks like it's in motion. The visible leg is also moved forward and re-angled, so it looks more active and doesn't just disappear into the wheel looks like it's in motion. The visible leg is also moved forward and re-angled, so it looks more active and doesn't just disappear into the wheel. It looks modern, almost sleek.
首先，“无障碍图标项目”将目标对准了标准的蓝白轮椅图标。他们创造了一个新图标，希望最终能够取代ISO标准。它仍然是蓝色背景上的白色轮椅人形，但头部和身体向前倾斜。手臂向后弯曲，仿佛在推动使用者，轮子看起来也在运动中。可见的腿也向前移动并重新调整了角度，看起来更具活力，而不仅仅是消失在轮子里。它看起来很现代，几乎很流畅。
You'll do a pretty good job picturing it if you imagine the new logo as the old logo, but a talusized. Changing an ISO standard isn't easy. A proposal has to be submitted and reviewed by ISO's Technical Committee on Graphical Symbols. Then it has to be considered by symbols experts from around the world and then finally approved by ISO's member countries. I talked with Barry Gray, the chairman of the Technical Committee on Graphical Symbols. Oh my God, I want Barry Gray's job.
如果你把新标志想象成旧标志的斜体版，你就能很好地描绘出它的样子。改变ISO标准并不容易。必须提交提案并由ISO图形符号技术委员会进行审查。然后必须由来自世界各地的符号专家进行审议，最后由ISO成员国批准。我采访了图形符号技术委员会主席巴里·格雷。天哪，我想做巴里·格雷的工作。
He says he's seen the new logo and applauds the designers for the icon's dynamism. But he told me a lot of factors would have to be taken into account before the current symbol could be replaced. Like whether this new icon might be confused with symbols used for wheelchair racing. So as much good as the current logo has done, Sarah Hendren, among others, takes issue with how the logo portrays people with disabilities. It has this immobile look to it. The figure in the image looks like it's waiting to be pushed around.
他说他看过新标志，并对设计师赋予图标的活力表示赞赏。但他告诉我，在替换当前符号之前，必须考虑许多因素。比如这个新图标是否会与用于轮椅竞速的符号混淆。因此，尽管当前标志做了很多好事，但萨拉·亨德伦等人对该标志描绘残疾人的方式提出了异议。它有一种不动的外观。图像中的人物看起来像是在等待被推来推去。
It's not that there's anything wrong with anyone who experiences mobility in that way. It's just that for Hendren, the implicit message the icon sense is that people with disabilities are helpless. In this new logo grants a sense of autonomy to the figure in the wheelchair. And there's a clear delineation between where the person starts and the chair begins. I think what the former icon lacked was that just wasn't any definition of moving forward. You know, it was just kind of, um, stoic. Whereas this symbol shows that the Maldon community is moving full steam ahead.
这并不是说以这种方式体验移动性的任何人有什么不对。只是对亨德伦来说，该图标传达的隐含信息是残疾人是无助的。这个新标志赋予了轮椅上的人一种自主感。并且对人的起点和椅子的起点有了清晰的划分。我认为前一个图标所缺乏的正是没有任何向前移动的定义。你知道，它只是一种，嗯，坚忍。而这个符号表明莫尔登社区正在全速前进。
We are all moving full steam ahead. Gary Christensen is the mayor of Maldon, Massachusetts, a town of about 60,000. 60,000 diverse residents. Mayor Christensen worked with a disability advocacy organization called Triangle to replace the old symbol all over Maldon. And he is really enthusiastic about it. He wants to have every conceivable spot here in Maldon replaced with this accessible icon project
我们都在全速前进。加里·克里斯滕森是马萨诸塞州莫尔登市的市长，这是一个拥有约6万名居民的小镇。6万名多元化的居民。克里斯滕森市长与一个名为“三角形”的残疾倡导组织合作，在整个莫尔登取代了旧符号。他对此充满热情。他希望让莫尔登的每一个可能的角落都换上这个无障碍图标项目……
as soon as possible. If you talk to Jeff Gentry from Triangle, he would tell you that I've emailed him, called him, texted him, pigeon carried them to find out when we can replace every symbol here in the city of Maldon. That's how we go right in to try and fulfill this wonderful initiative. At this point in our conversation,
尽快。如果你和“三角形”组织的杰夫·杰特里交谈，他会告诉你我给他发过邮件、打过电话、发过短信、甚至用信鸽联系过他，以弄清楚我们什么时候可以在莫尔登市更换每一个符号。这就是我们如何直接去尝试实现这一绝妙倡议的。在我们对话的这个时刻……
the mayor handed the phone over to Jeff Gentry from Triangle. Hi Lauren, how are you? Together, Triangle and the mayor's office have gotten the new logo at the Talbot's Distribution Center in Maldon and at Clark Shoes, which has its U.S. headquarters in Newton mass, not too far away. People with disabilities are no longer accepting separate but equal work, school and life opportunities.
市长把电话交给了“三角形”组织的杰夫·杰特里。嗨，劳伦，你好吗？“三角形”组织和市长办公室一起，将新标志带到了莫尔登的塔尔博特配送中心，以及不远处的牛顿市拥有美国总部的克拉克鞋业。残疾人不再接受分离但平等的工作、学校和生活机会。
They're moving forward towards a richer future. And hopefully the icon creates dialogue around that. And I believe that the accessible icon is creating a more inclusive world, like we're building here in Maldon. When I asked Pro new signage advocates about how they're expanding its use, they would point to local success stories elsewhere.
他们正朝着更富裕的未来前进。希望这个图标能围绕这一点展开对话。我相信无障碍图标正在创造一个更具包容性的世界，就像我们在莫尔登建造的那样。当我询问新标牌的倡导者他们如何扩大其使用范围时，他们会指向其他地方的本地成功案例。
Both Jeff Gentry and Sarah Hendren from the Accessible Icon project refer me to a guy named... My name is Brendan Hildriff Brendan Hildriff, a disability rights activist in North Carolina Hello, my name is Brendan. I am not a machine or robot. Brendan has cerebral palsy in hearing loss and speaks through an augmentative communication device or a talking machine. We reproduced it here using an interview transcript.
来自“无障碍图标项目”的杰夫·杰特里和萨拉·亨德伦都把我推荐给了一个叫……我叫布伦丹·希尔德里夫。布伦丹·希尔德里夫，北卡罗来纳州的残疾人权利活动家。你好，我叫布伦丹。我不是机器或机器人。布伦丹患有脑瘫和听力损失，并通过增强型通信设备或会说话的机器进行交流。我们这里使用采访记录将其复制下来。
This project is way more than just a picture and a symbol to me. The project to me shows that people with disabilities can be active and participate. It makes people understand about the disability's rights movement. Brendan has been working to bring the accessibility sign to his town, New Bern. I did a lot speaking with television and radio stations locally about the new icon. I have a letter from the state to allow me to use the icon here. I have painted the new icon in several businesses in New Bern, and still have many more to do. People at the North Carolina state level like the new icon, they thanked me for bringing
对我来说，这个项目不仅仅是一张图片和一个符号。这个项目向我表明，残疾人可以积极参与。它让人门了解残疾人权利运动。布伦丹一直致力于将无障碍标志带到他的小镇新伯恩。我在当地的电视和广播电台做了很多关于新图标的演讲。我有一封来自州的信，允许我在这里使用该图标。我在新伯恩的几家企业画了新图标，还有很多要做。北卡罗来纳州州级的人很喜欢这个图标，他们感谢我把……
the icon here, Jeff, Brian, and Sarah. As in, Jeff Gentry of Triangle and and Brian Glenny and Sarah Hendren from the accessible icon project. Realized how many businesses I am getting to use the new icon. Then they made me regional director of North Carolina for the icon project because I am kicking their butts in getting the icon out in the world. Sarah Hendren says she's not interested in what she calls signwashing, or getting the logo changed just to be politically correct.
图标带到了这里，杰夫、布莱恩和萨拉。也就是“三角形”组织的杰夫·杰特里，以及无障碍图标项目的布莱恩·格伦尼和萨拉·亨德伦。意识到有多少企业在使用这个图标后。然后他们让我担任图标项目北卡罗来纳州的区域总监，因为我在让图标走向世界方面表现得太棒了。萨拉·亨德伦说她对她所谓的“洗绿”不感兴趣，也就是为了政治正确而改变标志。
She says this project is a process of consciousness raising, quote unquote, so that each time the sign is officially changed, there's intention around it, and dialogue about disability. But a symbol meant to start dialogue and spread through grassroots action is very different than one created to be a universal and internationally recognized symbol. There's a lack of clarity as to whether this new sign meets the standards put into effect by the Americans with Disabilities Act. Even though the law states that reasonable changes can be made to this symbol as long as it clearly displays the wheelchair and indicates accessibility,
她说这个项目是一个提高意识的过程，也就是所谓的意识提升，这样每次正式更改标志时，都有其意图，并且有关于残疾的对话。但是，一个旨在引发对话并通过基层行动传播的符号，与一个旨在成为通用且国际认可的符号截然不同。这个新标志是否符合《美国残疾人法案》生效的标准，目前还缺乏明确性。尽管法律规定，只要明确显示轮椅并表明无障碍，就可以对符号进行合理的更改……
there are still questions about what constitutes a functional equivalent. New York City had planned to adopt the new logo in all five burrows, but this legal ambiguity caused them to hold off implementing it, at least for now. I think a lot of people end up buying that old original image because they're nervous about complying with ADA code. And I think what we're trying to do is say, look, functional equivalence has a kind of legal set of definitions and contours. Those are the things that are going to probably need to be worked out at the state level.
关于什么构成功能等效仍有疑问。纽约市曾计划在所有五个行政区采用新logo，但这种法律上的模棱两可导致他们搁置了实施，至少目前如此。我认为很多人最终还是购买了那个旧的原始图像，因为他们担心不符合ADA法典。我认为我们正在做的是说，看，功能等效有一套法律上的定义和轮廓。这些事情可能需要在州一级得到解决。
But it's not as though functional equivalence means really nilly personal interpretation. It means as long as it's perfectly clear that you're indicating access for wheelchair users, you can do a different kind of version of the icon. So it all comes back to the question of what we are trying to accomplish through our symbols. Having one unified icon can tell one clear story all over the world, but sometimes stories change. We said earlier that the group behind the original call for an international symbol
但这并不意味着功能等效意味着随心所欲的个人解释。这意味着只要完全清楚你是在指示为轮椅使用者提供无障碍设施，你就可以使用不同版本的图标。所以这一切都归结于我们试图通过符号实现什么的问题。拥有一个统一的图标可以在世界各地讲述一个清晰的故事，但有时故事会变。我们前面说过，最初呼吁建立国际符号的那个组织……
of access is called rehabilitation international. Well, in the 1940s, it was known by another name, the International Society for the welfare of cripples. The meanings and associations that words have shift over time, and sometimes the symbols need to as well. But you know, universality does have an upside, especially if you're in Belgrade, and you're about to accidentally eat poison. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Lauren Ober with Sam Greenspan, Avery, Truffleman, and me Roman Mars. This is the first time I've ever seen a Christmas tree with a Christmas tree by Lauren Ober with Sam Greenspan every truffleman and me Roman Mars.
无障碍设施被称为“国际康复”。嗯，在20世纪40年代，它有一个别的名字，叫做“国际残疾人福利协会”。词语的含义和联想随着时间的推移而发生变化，有时符号也需要随之改变。但你知道，普遍性确实有积极的一面，特别是如果你在贝尔格莱德，而且正要不小心吃到毒药的话。“99%隐形”本周由劳伦·奥伯与萨姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼以及我罗曼·马尔斯共同制作。这是我第一次见到一棵带有圣诞树的圣诞树……由劳伦·奥伯与萨姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼以及我罗曼·马尔斯制作。
Special thanks to Pike Malonovsky who helped with among other things pronouncing designer Susanna Kufu's name. So here comes a pronouncer for Susanne Kufu's. Which I'd like to point out is spelled K-O-E-F-O-E-D. Co-Foot. Let me say that again. Susanne. Co-Foot.
特别感谢派克·马洛诺夫斯基，他协助完成了诸如正确发音设计师苏珊娜·库福的名字等工作。所以这里是苏珊娜·库福的发音指南。我想指出的是，它的拼写是K-O-E-F-O-E-D。Co-Foot。让我再说一遍。苏珊娜。Co-Foot。
I do not hear the D in Co-Foot. Co-Foot. Co-Foot. Susanne. Co-Foot. I still don't know. That doesn't make sense to me at all. That's why you say that.
我听不到Co-Foot里的D。Co-Foot。Co-Foot。苏珊娜。Co-Foot。我还是不知道。这对我来说根本说不通。这就是为什么你这么说。
But then again, that's Danish for you. Cheers. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and produced at the offices of Arksign, an architecture firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars, Sam tweets at Sam listens, Avery tweets at Troubleman. Avery also runs our Tumblr, which is at 99%invisible.tumblr.com, which you'll really like. You should check it out.
话又说回来，这就是丹麦语。干杯。我们是旧金山91.7本地公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的建筑事务所Arksign的办公室制作。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。我在推特上是@RomanMars，萨姆是@Samlisters，艾弗里是@Troubleman。艾弗里还运营我们的Tumblr，网址是99%invisible.tumblr.com，你会非常喜欢的。你应该去看看。
But if you want to do this a real style of this week, go to 99pi.org, search for your favorite episode of 99%invisible, and then tweet on Facebook that sucker. Sharing is caring at 99pi.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但如果你想在这个星期以真正的方式做到这一点，请访问99pi.org，搜索你最喜欢的“99%隐形”单集，然后在Facebook上发推那个笨蛋。分享就是关爱，网址是99pi.org。广播塔皮奥。来自PRX。这集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。